hello everyone and welcome to the class
you've all been waiting for it is once
again Magnus Carlson versus Hikaru
Nakamura and it is truly a thrilling
game it lasts exactly 64 moves as there
are that many squares on the chessboard
so I don't know I thought you guys might
want to know that but even though it's a
fairly long game uh so much stuff is
happening mates are being threatened all
over the place uh the position is not
winning for Magnus now for Hikaru now I
mean uh absolute Madness so let's dive
straight into it and see what happened
Magnus has the white pieces and he opens
with Pawn to H4 which is uh odd but
there is a rook on H1 so it makes sense
you want to advance that pawn and Hikaru
does the same just Pawn to H5 we have D4
by Magnus now grabbing the center and
Hikaru plays Pawn to B5 which again
makes sense you open up your light
Square bishop and at some point you
might even threaten a nice Checkmate
here once you develop the queen so here
Pawn to C4 Magnus wants the free up his
Rook we have Fanta C5 and now C captures
on B5 uh that's not a c capture some V5
sorry C captures on B5 C captures on D4
and we have a rook trade Rook captures
Queen captures and now Pawn to B3
opening up the dark Square Bishop as
well uh Bishop to B6 he car does the
same now look at the bishop pair already
fully operational not something you will
see on move 6 in regular chess Knight
the F3 and now we have Queen to B7 and
already Hikaru with Incredible pressure
towards magnus's King if this Knight now
moves Queen captures and G2 will just be
checkmate
so you have to be very careful Ponte A4
by Magnus and now as the Knight cannot
move just Pawn to E5 Hikaru grabs the
full Center Ponte E3 of course Magnus
wants to challenge this D captures an E3
Knight captures and now uh you have to
decide whether you want to capture here
usually uh you might consider this but
it's such a beautiful Bishop pair you
didn't you don't really want to capture
this so you want to defend your E5 Pawn
with a move like D6 or Knight the G6 or
how Hikaru does it with Pawn to F6 and
okay we have pawned the B4 by Magnus now
having A5 in mind Knight the E6 and now
Bishop to B3 uh makes sense is not this
diagonal opened up so maybe D6 was
slightly better not allowing Magnus such
pressure against the black king Knight
the C7 and now we have Knight the F5 and
already uh the position explodes look at
this Knight the E8 Hikaru adds a
Defender here yeah to the G7 pawn and
now Knight the E7 check by Magnus King
to F7 and now Magnus is winning imagine
that only move 14 feel free to pause the
video and win this position for Magnus
well I'll give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on seeing really
far away and deep into the position as
this is not an easy one to see and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is night to C6 that's the move
that's the move that wins the game
incredible as it is uh Magnus did not
find it so really congratulations to all
of you who did uh really just a
spectacular move a point is now that you
don't really have a move uh what do you
play if you play D captures and C6 which
uh if you don't do this then the queen
is coming to F5 then the Knight captures
an E5 then the I mean the black is just
dead so D captures on C6 now you still
play Queen to F5 and now look at this uh
what do you play night if Knight the C7
to try and keep an eye on this knight uh
just the Knight captures on E5 with the
check and once the king moves just B
characters and C6 now attacks the queen
now if you go here Knight D7 check picks
up the queen so you have to go here and
I just spawn to A5 you win the bishop
and there's nothing to to be done here
and on the other hand after Queen F5 if
you play something like Queen E7 if you
try to defend it this way then you even
have Knight captures an E5 check now
again if you go here then Knights the G6
check will win the queen so you have to
go here and that's even worse than
Bishop captures and E6 comes with the
checks so you could go here I mean
there's nothing
so uh that that was in the position
however after King to F7 Magnus did not
find Knight to C6 he played Knight to G6
he attacked hikaru's Rook but now just
Rook to H6 and Hikaru is now perfectly
fine Queen to F5 and now even Knights
the of course you cannot capture if you
capture on G6 then of course Knight
captures an E5 check picks up the rook
and again Magnus is winning so after
Queen F5 Knight to D6 now attacks the
queen and now uh Knight G captures an E5
with check very important it seems like
you should play this Knight captures to
leave this Knight on such an active
Outpost but after King E8 now your queen
is hanging and also the Knight here is
hanging so you're just gonna lose so
Magnus plays the correct night night G
captures on E5 with check King to E8 and
now we have Queen to D3 this is how he
saves uh the position now if you capture
an E5 then Magnus will cap run D6 so
Knight the E4 and now Magnus just cast
King side I'm sure you forgot that was a
possibility F characters on E5 we have
Bishop captures on E5 and now Rook the
G6 he kind of brings The Rook into the
attack and if you count the pieces you
will see that Magnus has three minor
pieces and Hikaru has four minor pieces
so Hikaru has an extra peace magnet
sacrificed for the attack now let's see
where the attack is Pawn to A5
challenges the bishop Bishop to C7 and
now Pawn to A6 challenges the queen
queen to B6 and now Bishop to D5 so uh
what do you play here of course the
Knight is hanging you have to capture on
D5 Bishop captures on D5 Queen captures
and now we have Knight the F6 attacking
the White Queen Queen to A8 with check
and now we have King the E7 and now just
Rook the E1 aligning The Rook nicely
with the king and the file uh and Hikaru
plays Rook the G4 uh very nicely done
goes after the pawn here but also on
much more active Square for the rook and
now what can magnets do here he plays
Bishop cat press on C7 Queen captures
and now Knight to E5 attacking the rook
and G4 and he also has a very nice
control of the back rank also if the
Rook captures on B4 then maybe nice the
G6 check could be an idea even though
Rook captures on B4 is precise here it's
uh you have to calculate a lot through
capture some B4 then Knights the G6
check and uh well it's just uh what do
you play if you play King to F7 then I
back to E5 check so of course you have
to go back so you have to realize you
have to go to D6 and already you feel a
bit unpleasant even though you you are
surviving here after all you are up a
piece you will survive this but that's a
lot to see uh in Rapid chess and I mean
you are playing against Magnus so maybe
just don't do that just yet so Queen to
C3 Hikaru goes for the other best move
that is attacking the Knight on E5 and
also the Rook on E1 so King the F1 and
now this very nice Queen characters and
B4 again Rook captures on B4 is better
but he just doesn't want to calculate
all of this Knight G6 Madness going with
the King to D6 so Queen captures on B4
and now Magnus just plays Knight
captures on G4 Knight captures and now
Magnus has to figure out how to play
this he does have a rook against two
knights but his King is a bit vulnerable
and if he wants he can claim a draw here
right away it's not a clear how but Rook
captures on E6 will allow that after d
captures Queen captures an A7 you have
two connected fast pawns for for a
knight and as long as you control F2 you
will not get checkmated so that that
will be sufficient material for a draw
but after Knight captures on G4 Queen
capture Sun A7 was played by Magnus
right away and now Knight the age to
with check maybe he missed this maybe he
didn't it's hard to say so the thing is
you cannot go to E2 if you try to save
your Rook you're not gonna be able to
save it just Queen B5 check and now King
to D2 Knight to F1 with check and now
you will have to give up The Rook
otherwise if you go King to C3 or
something you're just gonna get
destroyed Queen to see for checking the
B2 and now the queen will connect with
the rook and that's just it so instead
after Knight H2 check King to G1 by
Magnus now comes Queen capture Sunny one
king captures an H2 and now Queen to E5
with check very important to grab the B
Pawn not allow both of the pawns to
start marching forward G3 and queen
captures on V5 and you have this
position where Magnus is up a pawn and
it's a beautiful past a six Pawn so only
two moves for it to become a queen but
Hikaru is up at night so can Hikaru win
this uh Queen to B7 Magnus offers a
queen trade and of course you cannot
accept this if you accept it then the
Knight then the pawn will become a queen
that's Unstoppable so after Queen B7 we
have Queen to C5 of course he declines
it and he goes for the F2 pawn and now
Magnus should play A7 and just allow the
capture of the pawn now whether he's saw
this or not maybe he decided that he
just didn't want to draw because if you
allow this is just to draw King H1 and
the two pawns are preventing the knight
from entering the uh the game and
attempting some sort of a checkmating
attack so you will now either get a
queen or black will have to settle for a
nice Perpetual check here
but okay Magnus goes King to G1 he
defends the F2 Pawn instead and now
Queen to C1 check by Hikaru King H2
Queen to C7 now offering a queen trade
uh Queen to B4 check and now King the E8
and this is uh I mean uh both players
are in time trouble this is move 38 and
it's a ridiculous that King to d8 is
winning here King 38 because the king
needs to be as close as possible to the
pass Pawn you need to have the king to
d8 then you can go to C8 to B8 in the
future but after King to E8 that one
square will be a bit too much now Magnus
goes Queen to B5 uh and now what can
Hikaru do uh he should again continue
with King 38 Queen to B5 didn't really
do all that much he's going after the H5
Pawn but it doesn't really matter King
38 is just winning for Hikaru but okay
Pawn to G6 we have Queen to D3 now
Magnus really wants to grab that at
kingside pawn and now look at this queen
to B6 he gives up the G6 Pawn with check
so he is able to start marching with the
King to the queen side which he could
have done right from the start but okay
Queen captures on G6 Queen to d8 King 38
and now King the G1 not allowing Queen
characters on F2 Queen captures an A6
and now Queen captures on H5 so now
Magnus lost the past Apon but he does
have three connected pass pawns on the
king side so Queen A1 check we have King
to G2 and now Queen to D4 will uh hikar
will be able to do something with the
Knight we'll see uh Queen to F5 now
Magna centralizes the queen well Hikaru
really centralized the queen Magnus and
takes the second best Square King to E7
and now Ponte H5 Magnus starts advancing
his other pass Pawn towards the queening
square uh uh Queen to G7 and now uh you
again have to be very careful if you
play a weird move let's say you play
something like base than Knight to F4
check just picks up the queen so you
have to be careful as long as that King
is in the reach of your knight you you
cannot relax so Pawn to F4 we have Pawn
to D5 Hikaru also starts marching his
Pawn forward with the same idea of
course if Magnus captures Hikaru just
wins the queen uh the the master of
puzzle rush you know uh wastes no time
pushing that Pawn King to H3 and now
Pawn to D4 we have Queen to D5 and now
Queen to F6 and Magnus starts bringing
the king deeper into the position King
to G4 we have King to f8 and now Magnus
is down only to 15 seconds on the clock
he karaoke has something below a minute
King to F3 King to G7 King to E4 and now
King the H6 putting pressure on that H5
Pawn with King to D3 and now Queen to E7
uh Queen to E5 and now Queen to A3 with
check with King the E2 and now uh Hikaru
has to be very careful look at those
pawns controlling G5 and uh G6 if Hikaru
does a weird move let's say play some
like Queen B3 he defends his Knight
there goes Queen to h8 Checkmate so uh
Hikaru wasn't very happy about this he
go he went Queen to be to check King F3
Queen to B7 check King to G4 and now
Queen to ca threatening all sorts of
nasty discoveries so Magnus just goes
backing F3 Queen to C6 check King to G4
and now King the H7
uh preventing that uh a queen to h8 move
so Queen F5 check King to h8 with Queen
the F6 check King to G8 and now uh Queen
to G6 with check with king h8 queen to
F6 checking G8 Queen to G6 and King
danger it doesn't matter if you go to f8
it's still a draw only you allow magnets
to start advancing his pass Pawn but
here King day trade and it was in this
position on move 64 as advertised that
the game ended in a draw as there is no
way for either side to make progress
um so uh very nicely done uh Hikaru was
winning first Magnus was winning then
Hikaru was winning and in the end uh
they they share half a point each and
you don't really you don't really have a
way of continuing this if I mean you you
could still try something like Ponte H6
but I mean you could also lose the game
and with both players now being very low
on time they agreed that okay let's
let's stop playing this game immediately
and we're gonna play another one but
this one is a draw
uh yeah so very nicely done by both of
them I I enjoyed it immensely hope you
guys did as well and I mean uh it's uh
very nice I I know that this chess 960
business is is too much for some of you
but it's only five days a year so you
know it um that does add a certain
amount of refreshment to the to the
world of Chess and then after that we
are continuing with usual stuff uh until
next year uh unless they will have like
a lot of FIFA random tournaments but uh
I I doubt it at least not maybe next
year at some point I'm sure there will
be as well that's the game I hope you
guys enjoyed it uh we're gonna discuss
the uh the standings after we show at
least one more game but for those of you
who are interested another vocabulous
absolutely crushed the field he has nine
and a half out of ten uh I mean that
that guy is just incredible I mean
whoever will face him uh in the in the
semi-finals uh better you know better
come ready uh but yeah that's the game I
hope you guys enjoyed it uh I would like
to wish a very happy birthday to Stearn
and I would like to thank Jeff Morrow
Johan Nathan Hesley and uh Jacko beat
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this fine
event until it finishes uh so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day